schrader was kann da am filmset passiert
sein
morgen zunächst war die betroffenheit
zum ausdruck bringen ist ein sehr
schlimmer unfall
das passiert in der regel auch nur sehr
sehr selten dass unfälle im zusammenhang
mit solchen dingen passieren allerdings
müssen wir jetzt abwarten was die
ermittlungen den usa bringt das könnten
rückstände aus einer firma für gewesen
sein die rausgeschleudert worden ist
allerdings aufgrund der schwere der
verletzung und der todesfolge gehe ich
davon aus dass hier entweder eine
falsche sache zum einsatz kamen oder
entsprechend falsch munition verwendet
wurde die so auch gar nicht dafür
gedacht war wie gesagt müssen wir jetzt
ab dass wir weiter und ermittlungen der
behörden wird zeigen was heißt in diesem
fall falsche waffe was für waffen werden
normalerweise am filmset benutzt sind
das tatsächlich echte schusswaffen oder
sind das eigentlich spielzeugpistolen
naja spielzeugpistolen sind es in den
seltensten fällen die meisten fällen
sind es spezielle film machen das sind
durchaus auch scharfe schusswaffen die
umgebaut worden höchsten machern von
fachleuten die das handwerk gelernt
haben so dass man in der regel dort auch
keine scharfe munition geladen kann mit
einer waffe die tatsächlich auch scharfe
munition verschießen kann wird selten
auch im film gearbeitet allerdings dann
nur von speziell ausgebildeten leuten
die auch entsprechende waffenrechtliche
genehmigung dazu haben und die
fachkenntnisse solche waffen müssen
speziell gewartet werden und es bedarf
einer enormen fachkenntnis die waffe
entsprechend vorzubereiten für die
filmaufnahmen hier gelten besondere
vorschriften der unfallverhütung
gesetzlichkeiten her ein bisschen
gereinigt werden dass davon ein ganz
spezieller munition verwendet werden
eine kombination die möglichst keine
oder kaum rückstände hinterlässt und
dann ist es auch noch eine frage der
distanz zu den darstellern ob da nicht
auch noch unfälle passieren könnten also
selbst mit der besten film munition und
kartuschen munition kann es passieren
dass so kleine verletzung auftreten auf
kommt von leuten die leute raus da
führen können aber das ist hier in
diesem fall wahrscheinlich nicht
passiert man kann jetzt nicht
spekulieren was der hintergrund ist so
wie das aussieht wird hier mit
sicherheit ganz ober fehler begangen
worden seien es gab ja einen ähnlichen
fallen zwar mit dem sohn von bruce lee
dem kung fu darstelle brandon lee sein
sohn das war 1993 gibt es da parallelen
beschreiben sie nochmal den fall von
damals auch
in diesem fall 1993 das ist ja auch
bekannt hat es sich wohl um einen
rückstand gehandelt er noch im lauf
eines revolvers vorhanden war welche
waffe dort genau zum einsatz kam kann
ich ihnen leider nicht sagen wir wissen
wo das war ein revolver eine ganz
tragische geschichte
und dort hat sich im lauf ein rückstand
sekunden der tatsächlich durch eine
platzpatrone derart beschleunigt wurde
dass der schauspieler den versetzungen
dann relativ schnell legen ist also
durch innere blutung in diesem fall zum
tod gekommen auch hier um das man sagen
dass die waffe definitiv vorher nicht
ordnungsgemäß vorbereitet worden die
wachtmeister die am films verantwortlich
sind für solche schusswaffen sind
natürlich auch gehalten ganz extrem
strenge kontrollen durchzuführen und die
war von modernen aus der hand zu geben
wo noch einzusetzen wenn man sich
absolut sicher ist dass da nichts
passieren kann und ich denke mal das
wollte ich ja auch vernachlässigt und
dem ergebnis dass es gab es diesen
personen gibt es da unterschiedliche
sicherheitsstandards in europa und den
usa denn wie wir alle wissen sind die
waffengesetze in den usa ja nun ganz
andere als hier bei uns
das ist vollkommen richtig hier muss man
natürlich auch sagen dass wir in europa
ganz andere gegebenheiten haben weil
auch der gesetzliche basis
das ist hier wesentlich ausgeschlossen
dass solche unfälle passieren das
waffengesetz deutschland zum beispiel
ist eines der restriktivsten
welches wort und die dkv vorschriften
die im zusammenhang mit waffen
darstellen oder szenischen darstellung
hier
zugrunde liegen sind auch sehr sehr
sicherheitsbewusst gefasst und ziemlich
streng ausgelegt so dass man davon
ausgehen kann dass es in den usa
etwas lockerer zu viert spitze stehen
nun ist das natürlich auch ein schock
für alec baldwin selbst da in so einer
situation plötzlich die kamerafrau zu
erschießen werden die schauspieler für
den umgang mit solchen waffen noch mal
speziell geschult oder wie muss man sich
die situation am set auch vorstellen ist
da der aufnahmeleiter der sich die
waffen noch mal im letzten moment auch
noch mal anschaut und checkt
in der regel ist es so dass man am set
den lochen meister hat also eine
verantwortliche person die speziell
geschult und ausgebildet ist und auch
für die waffen verantwortlich ist und
diese personen hat die waffen unter
verschluss und wird sich vorbereiten für
den film auftrag und je nachdem was
umgebung erfordert ist entsprechend
präparieren und dann den schauspieler
natürlich auch auf irgendwelche diesen
gebrauch der waffe einweisen also
zumindest es hier bei uns ist es üblich
weiß nicht wie es noch nie gemacht aber
ich denke das wird ähnlich gehandhabt
dass die darsteller selbstverständlich
im vorfeld eine ordentliche einweisung
von der verantwortlichen person
anzureisen die werden dann übergeben ist
werden wohl auch probeschüssen
durchgeführt es wurde dass man hinterher
sicher sein kann dass auch der
darsteller in der kopf situation der
airport eine wartung der hand hält weiß
was er tun es werden sicherheitsabstände
festgelegt und das werden auch prozedere
für den notfall festgelegt und das alles
ist aufgabe dieser person um die burg
ist verantwortlich für die waffen
[Musik]